Well,
how are you? Cristian Cásseres greets you with
his new News Now program in
Spanish, there are only days left until
Superbowl 56, the game is a
very special day for businesses,
restaurants and bars here in Las Vegas.
Americans listen to this and
consume 1.4 billion
Chicken wings during the game, however, there are
some ingredients that will not be
included in this year's menu or
will possibly be more expensive. Their
restaurants are preparing to
please their customers early and
changing the subject, just face masks here
in the state of Nevada like this.  The governor said so
if alone in a conference
given on Thursday morning, however,
there are exceptions to the rule, the
Clark County School District still requires the
use of face masks on buses, the
rest will be able to make their own decision and
continue with the elimination.  of the
mask, local casinos were
quick to approve this new measure
with great satisfaction as they hope that it will be
This will attract more tourists to the city
especially with the arrival of
spring and summer the casinos
are also optimistic that this
change will help
the las vegas economy a bit more however there are
some places where it is not optional i
heard this from the  hospitals clinics
buses taxis and other transport measures such
as left and über airports
and also planes companies
can also make their own decisions
regarding their employees and customers and we
close the week with a truly
spectacular day we will have a fairly
sunny day with pleasant temperatures
reaching 75 degrees some areas
of the valley reaching about 80 degrees for
the next week the temperatures will drop a little more
and we will see a little breeze
with a slight chance of rain
for Tuesday I am cristian cásseres with your
informative church brake a spanish
good day
[Music]